Take the foundling to the city of
Caledon on the forest planet of Corvus
there you'll find Ahsoka Tano
tell her you were sent by Bo Katan
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new mandalorian season 2 ahsoka tano
video that's right we finally get ahsoka tano in
live action so we'll break it all down there's a
bunch of easter eggs i'll explain what she's been
doing this whole time there's a big missing gap
of time that they have to explain during the
mandalorian season 2 episodes of what she's
been doing we'll do a giveaway for disney plus
memberships all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave all your theories about
ahsoka on the video big spoiler warning for
everything that's happened on the mandalorians
so far if you haven't seen any of the episodes
and you just happen to be watching this video but
i'll number these as we go along and talk about
easter eggs starting with number 10 at the end
of the mandalorian season 2 episode 3 boca tan
played by katie sakhoff tells the mandalorian he
can find ahsoka tano on the city of kaladan on
the forest planet of corvus i mentioned in my full
season 2 episode 3 easter egg video the corvus is
actually an easter egg for idon versio's inferno
squad the ship that they used was called corvus
and i didn't learn until after the episode had
aired but the actress who plays iden versio janina
gavin carr she actually had a special secret
cameo during the mandalorian season 2 episode 3
but it wasn't his iden versio she guest starred
as that mon calamari in the docks who fixed
the mandalorian ship if you can believe it it's
sort of like mark hamill showing up in cameoing
as the ev99 droid you just don't know it's them
unless they tell you but bogatan doesn't really
explain anything about what's been going on with
ahsoka for the past 10 years forget everything
that happened after the clone boards order 66
the events of the original trilogy we'll have
to find that out from ahsoka herself when we meet
her in a future episode and for those of you that
are expecting to see her in episode four just a
big reminder that carl weathers actually directed
episode four dave filoni wrote in directed episode
five so don't be surprised if in episode four we
only get maybe like a tag scene at the end like
a post-credits scene with ahsoka and we don't
get the full ahsoka episode until episode 5. it
just makes sense that dave filoni helped create
the ahsoka character she's so precious to him and
george lucas who also helped create the character
that he would direct the episode where she appears
in live action for the first time in fun fact 2
when katie sackoff's boca tan says her name ahsoka
tano that's the first time her name has been said
in any live-action star wars story movie or tv
series they've actually been attempts to do ahsoka
in live action before dave filoni revealed that at
one time they thought about officially retconning
attack of the clones so that this little girl
would have been ahsoka but he said the reason
why they didn't do that is because the little girl
is way too young to be ahsoka because of the way
the timeline works out you have to remember that
attacking the clones is happening right before the
clone wars because that begins right at the end of
that movie in ahsoka was 14 during the clone wars
season one this little girl looks like she's maybe
eight years old so way too young to be ahsoka
but there are a couple big missing gaps of time
where we don't know exactly what ahsoka was doing
so between the events of star wars rebels sabine
giving Bo Katan the darksaber then reuniting with
ahsoka after the clone wars ezra bridger saving
her from the sith temple using the star wars
version of time travel that's right there is
time travel in star wars it's called the world
between worlds it works a little bit like the
quantum realm in the marvel movies like avengers
end game and ant-man and the wasp they use this
space between spaces this extra-dimensional realm
of pure force energy to travel through space and
time but what you have is is that right at the end
of star wars rebels you have her going back into
one of the portals and then disappearing for the
events of the original trilogy we know what some
of the characters from this episode from rebels
were doing during the original trilogy ahsoka was
basically on a jedi walkabout during that period
then she shows up right after return of the jedi
in the battle of jakku to go with sabine into the
unknown regions to find ezra bridger so there's
about six or seven missing years of ahsoka's life
where she's traveling around the galaxy we don't
know exactly what she's doing sabine was actually
very active with the rebellion during that period
and obviously we know that boca tan was leading
the mandalorians and then they have the great
purge and then she became a pirate basically
with the night owls just raiding all the imperial
ships and then eventually maf gideon ships after
the empire fell so really only sabine and bogatan
were close by when all this stuff in the original
trilogy with luke skywalker darth vader emperor
palpatine was happening what happened right before
ahsoka disappeared is that ezra saves her from
the sith temple as she's fighting with darth vader
then emperor palpatine sensed them peeping him
through the world between worlds and he tried to
kill them enter and take control of the nexus they
both wind up escaping but the portal that ahsoka
escaped through took her to a different point
in time at this sith temple so she goes back to
the same place but it just at some point after
her fight with darth vader then all that dave
filoni has said about her during the events of the
original trilogy is that she basically like i said
went on jedi walkabouts commune with the force and
seek her own path kind of what happened to obi-wan
after he went to tatooine and dropped luke off
with the lars we'll learn a little bit more about
that during the obi-wan kenobi series he didn't
just sip tea until luke became a teenager and he
handed him anakin skywalker's lightsaber he did
have some adventures that's what they're going to
cover during the obi-wan series they're going to
be filming that early next year it'll premiere in
2022 but it was also during that period where
qui-gon appeared to him and taught him how to
become a force spirit that's why he was able to
become one when he died there's a lot of rules
about who can become four spirits sith can't do
it the reason why anakin skywalker was able to
do it even though he never formally learned how to
do it is because beings that are very powerful in
the force are very connected to the force can also
become four spirits that's sort of the cheat work
around rule normal jedi like yoda or obi-wan have
to learn the technique before they can actually
turn into four spirits anakin was the chosen one
so he just kind of a special case so during the
events of the original trilogy when ahsoka is on
walkabout around the outer rim territories you
have to assume she's doing something similar like
this too just deepening her bond with the force
the events of the mandalorian season 2 right now
where we are take place about six years after
return of the jedi the scene of her taking off
into the unknown regions with sabine is about one
year after return of the jedi so there's another
missing couple of years when she's flying around
with sabine all over this area of space there
are virtually no hyperspace lanes or official
maps or recorded data on the unknown regions
that's why they're called the unknown regions
but assuming that Bo Katan and the night owls have
been raiding imperial ships and then moff gideon
ships for a while now and it sounds like from her
speech as she says ahsoka has been around for a
little while too so that means within the last
couple of years she's come back from the outer
rim so it's possible that she found where ezra
was i'll talk about those rebels characters again
in a second too because there's all this talk of
doing spin-off mandalorian series on disney plus
so there's just a lot of recent story from the
last 10 years that they have to cover from ahsoka
like what were the adventures she was having
during the events of the original trilogy
and what did she find when she was in the
unknown regions up to the last couple of years
rosario dawson is going to be playing her we don't
know exactly what she's going to look like but i
think a lot of this fan art is pretty close ahsoka
is meant to be in her early 40s when this is all
happening so rosario dawson is about the right age
to play her just in terms of how much ahsoka will
be in season two like how many episodes i think
it's a boba fett situation where she's really
important to the story of season two and critical
but she's only in a couple episodes with the idea
that she could come back in future seasons in an
even bigger way there were also a lot of rumors
that they were developing in ahsoka disney plus
spin-off series and they would do some more of
the star wars rebels characters like sabine ezra
maybe even grand admiral thrawn on that the ceo of
disney as well as jon favreau dave flony have all
talked about them creating this new interconnected
group of disney plush shows that follow different
characters and stories but they're all loosely
connected with this overarching story so it's
sort of like the marvel cinematic universe but
with star wars disney plus series so for instance
you have all the bogotan night owl story talking
about retaking mandalore the darksaber reclaiming
her throne and naming herself the new mandalore
you could do a lot of that on a separate series
but obviously you still have moff gideon who's
a mandalorian character so they share a lot
of story elements between those two series
and then you have all the ahsoka stuff that
we're going to learn about during season two
in ahsoka such a big character it would be weird
if she only showed up a couple times during the
mandalorian and then you never saw her again
in any other live-action productions but there
were also rumors that she could potentially show
up in cameo on the other series that are taking
place at other points in the timeline while she
was still alive so rosario dawson for instance
could show up on the obi-wan series briefly
because she was alive during that period but
if you didn't watch all the clone wars episodes
that's really where most of her history is covered
so what happened was she started out as anakin's
padawan but before she formally finished her
training and became a jedi knight she was framed
for a crime she didn't commit the jedi counsel at
the time refused to believe she was innocent and
threw her under the bus it caused her to lose all
faith in the jedi so she left the order but if
you remember me doing videos for the clone wars
season seven episodes earlier this year during
that they tell the story of what ahsoka did while
she was on her own and how she came back to help
boca tan with the mandalorians retake mandalore
from darth maul in the shadow collective crime
syndicate that's how bogatan came to respect her
so much and why she speaks of her so highly when
she's explaining ahsoka to the mandalorian then
right after this is happening here her burying all
her comrades she goes to hiding in the outer rim
territories to ground having minor adventures for
a while she and anakin skywalker who had become
darth vader by this point start to have visions of
each other then they have a rematch a couple years
later during the events of star wars rebels in the
sith temple and for those of you asking if ahsoka
ever met or knew luke skywalker or leia anakin's
children she'd never actually met them in person
but luke eventually later in his life found out
who she was and learned about her connection to
anakin skywalker now because dave filoni and john
favreau are writing a lot of new story for ahsoka
just creating this weaving it into the canon it's
possible that they retcon some elements and she
could always have some story where she does
cross paths with luke skywalker in the future
my full mandalorian season 2 episode 4 video will
post on friday just like normal but before that i
will do more bonus videos for bogatan maf gideon
the darksaber and the mandalorians there's so
much to talk about after episode three they just
revealed so many big details everyone leave all
your video requests in the comments below if you
have any specific questions you want me to address
in a video congratulations lucas chong you're the
giveaway winner from my last big star wars video
please email me on the about page of my channel
so i can get your contact details everyone click
here for my full mandalorian season 2 episode 3
video and click here for my mandalorian season 2
luke skywalker video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!